a week ago we told you about a
bipartisan group of lawmakers who put
together a compromise package for
coronavirus relief
it looked then like it might sail
through but no longer
joining us now from west virginia
senator joe manchin
a leading member of the gang of eight
pushing that plan
senator is the gang of eights
compromised 908 billion dollars
is that plan now dead and is there a
chance
that congress may leave town for the
year
without passing any coveted relief at
all
well first of all chris the plan is
alive and well and there is no way
no way that we're going to leave
washington without taking care of the
emergency needs of our people
and that's all of our country in my
state of west virginia too
that they're they're all hurting
everywhere
but it seems you've got and i'm going to
get into some specifics in a minute
you've got the president pushing one
plan
uh senate majority leader uh mcconnell
pushing another nancy pelosi and the
democrats at third
you know it seemed as i say a week ago
like maybe they were all going to come
together behind your plan
there's an awful lot of talk that
negotiations have fallen apart
well here's the thing it hasn't fallen
apart we've been meeting day and night
for the last month we were on a call
all day yesterday we get on the call
again this afternoon to finish things up
we'll have a bill produced for the
american people tomorrow 908 billion
dollars
now chris the bottom line is on there's
a lot of parts to this bill
and in the spirit of compromise you have
to work through all of that
but at the end you can't be let the
perfect be the enemy of the good
there's going to be individually if you
put a bill up there some members
wouldn't vote for certain parts of the
bill
but when you put them all together and
look at the good it does for our country
in the most emergency way that we need
it this is only until april one
we're trying to get through the toughest
first quarter of our country that we've
ever faced
and we've got people without nutrition
we have people without shelter we have
people without paychecks
they're unemployed we have hospitals
being overburden we
have healthcare workers we have schools
that need to be attended to
this covers all of that and we give all
the small businesses a chance
to survive until the first quarter by
then we should start to come out with a
vaccine
that should be helping us and joe biden
will be our president and
make a determination what more is needed
this is strictly an emergency measure
but but i just want to make it clear the
bill you're talking about tomorrow is a
bill that the gang of eight agrees on
you don't have majority support in the
senate you don't have majority support
in the house
let me ask you about some of the
alternatives
that are out there now and let's if you
if you don't mind a lightning round
quick questions quick answers
president trump says president trump
says forget the unemployment benefits
just send a single
stimulus check six hundred dollars to
each american
is that a good idea i'm it's a bad idea
and i hope he reevaluates that statement
because basically
you if you're sending a stimulus check
of 600 or whatever it may be it was 1200
before
you're sending it to people that still
have a paycheck and still have a job
if you send a check to an unemployed
person you're sending a person has no
lifeline
it's done at the end of this month
they've got nothing we're going to three
hundred
dollars extended for 16 weeks i think
that's much more
reasonable practical and much needed
all right republican leaders still want
some liability protection for businesses
so people
when they go to a restaurant or a school
or whatever can't then sue and say you
gave me covet
democrats still want a lot of aid to
cities and states but
the republicans don't like the
democratic idea the democrats don't like
the republican idea
is that still the holdup well the spirit
of compromise is this everybody's not
going to get what they
want we can get something we could all
live with but we're putting a product
forward
it's going to go forward with both with
everything hopefully in it you'll see a
complete
bill tomorrow before the end of the day
then you can choose if you like it or
not vote for to vote against it
look at the good it does as a whole not
an individual piece
there's nobody that wants a business to
be litigated out of business
they're going to be tough enough just
surviving on the other hand we don't
want to throw caution to the wind that
the businesses aren't safe places
to work the workers not protected and
the people that go for
the patronize these places of businesses
are not in a safe environment
we have to take all that in
consideration do the best we can i
remind you this it's for a short period
of time
a short period we're not changing the
tort laws forever we're just trying to
get through an emergency period of time
all right some senators are saying look
liability is an issue aid to cities and
states is an issue let's forget about
both of those in this bill
and just stick aid specifically to
unemployed workers and aid to small
businesses on
the billiard that you've got to pass to
keep the government running to avoid a
shutdown
forget about that other stuff for now
what do you think about that idea
oh chris that's the easy way that's the
easy way out we can forget about the
tough things that's what we've been
doing for 10 years or more
no one wants to take a tough vote we're
all afraid it's going to hurt in the
election
we're here to take tough votes we're
here to help a country that's having a
tremendous
hardship going on right now and it's
going to get worse before it gets better
so with that being said that's the easy
way we can drop off both
liability and drop off aids to states
but states and municipalities especially
they're on the front line you want your
services to go essential services
first responders firemen policemen you
want all those to be in jeopardy
of the services that we depend on and
need to let it fall apart and think we
can pick it back up
you want the airlines to collapse you
want all these things to go by the
wayside
we don't we're going to make the tough
tough selection now if the rest of the
caucus won't go along with it
they'll decide what they can throw out
if the leaders can't come together but
we
worked as a bipartisan group and we've
grown over the month
we've got a good product that's been
vetted in so many different ways
and anything i can tell you we've done
what this place is supposed to do we've
worked together
we didn't work apart and condemn each
other and point fingers at them we've
got a good product and we want the
american people to know
that america we can do it in a
bipartisan way we can do it and we're
going to do it
senator manchin you've done a very good
job of selling your plan
you have not done a good job of
convincing me though it's going to get
passed by congress in the next week
well there's no guarantee there's
there's there's 535
people that's in that have to vote 535.
i can't guarantee they're all going to
vote for it and pass it but i can tell
you one thing
what's the alternative what are you
going to do we've given one month
day and night our our staffs have worked
around the clock
we've done everything we can to put an
all-inclusive product together
pick whatever parts you like whatever
parts you don't like put it all together
or take it as a whole
we're going to give it to you the way we
think the american people need it in an
emergency situation
we need this legislation
senator manchin i want to switch to just
one other subject we've got a little
uh we got a short less than two minutes
left do any
of joe biden's nominees members of his
team
give you heartburn uh for instance uh
you back when
barack obama appointed dr vivek murthy
as surgeon general you
oppose that uh he's now being renamed by
uh joe biden dr murthy for surgeon
general
you've got javier becerra for hhs is
there anybody that he has named so far
that you think i'm not sure i can vote
to confirm
them well let me be very clear i've been
very differential
with president trump president obama's
before and i'll be very differential
with president
biden i think a president will put their
team together unless that person has
done something wrong or totally runs a
muck of what i believe
and what i represent the state of west
virginia then basically i
always have said okay put your team
together they their will and pleasure
if they screw up and they're bad you're
going to be held accountable
and in four years the people can atone
that so i've been very differential i'm
going to look at each one of them there
might be some that i don't agree with
i will be able to let the biden
administration know how i feel but we
haven't done
the personal interviews yet before we
confirm i look forward to that
senator manchin thank you thanks for
joining us and good luck this week and
coming up with the relief package lord
knows the country
needs it thank you sir hey chris we're
going to do it
people believe in america this is a
great country and the people need help
right now
so we can be great again and we'll make
it happen we will
well the power of positive thinking